it's no secret that cat noir loves
making puns whenever the opportunity
arises
let's sometimes his flirtatious jokes
can make for some super awkward moments
watch until the end to find out which
one of adrian's flirty comments took
things away too far stormy weather
ladybug and cat noir might be super
close crime-fighting friends but that's
where ladybug draws the line cat noir
has made his feelings for her very
obvious and has gotten turned down time
and time again no time for your childish
charm cat noir but that's never stopped
him from making the best out of a bad
situation in stormy weather cat noir is
about to get struck by a thunderbolt
when ladybug swoops in to save the day
the heroes are thrown backward where
they roll on top of each other before
coming to a halt but instead of jumping
back up and catching stormy weather
cat noir puss is flirting to the test
and totally gets shut down yeah that
wasn't awkward at all the evilest Raider
cat noir might be in love with ladybug
but that's never stopped him from
flirting with other people and by other
people we mean Marinette in evilest
Raider
ladybug tasks cat noir with watching
over Marinette please it'll be a cinch
so he makes his way to Mara Nets front
door and finds her being yelled at by
Sabrina
cat noir starts flirting with Maron act
right off the bat and it's the most
awkward thing ever
he makes puns gets down on one knee and
kisses her hand the cat noir learning
performance is far from over
he goes on to flex his muscles and leans
in super close to Mary's face this scene
was jam-packed with so much cringe it
was hard to watch out feature the rest
anti bug in anti bug we find out that
Chloe and Sabrina like dressing up as
ladybug and cat noir when no one is
watching however a run-in with jagged
stone puts their friendship in jeopardy
Chloe totally shuns Sabrina pretending
she doesn't exist I don't see anyone
which causes her to be Akuma ties into
the Vanisher after finding out that
Sabrina is the Vanisher this invisible
person it's obvious ladybug and cat noir
exists Chloe's home but not before CAD
Noir snags a red flower and hands it
over to his one and only Bugaboo
but sadly ladybug pretends like nothing
happens and places the flower back into
the closest vase cat Noir got shut down
big time and the awkward look on his
face success at all
tongue the food income food Marinette
Chinese uncle comes to France to
demonstrate his stellar cooking skills
however everything goes wrong when Chloe
sabotages the chef and humiliates him in
front of the judges
great uncle Wang guess Akuma ties into
Kong food and ladybug and cat noir come
to the rescue cat Noir and ladybug wind
up in an elevator together and cat noir
13 goes to the next level he shoots her
a flirtatious look leans in close and
says ladybug come on it's just you and
me together we could go places ladybug
quickly dismisses him by saying yeah
like up cat noir tried a little too hard
and took things a little too far in the
scene stormy weather story weather is
one of those episodes that showcases cat
noir showering ladybug with puns jokes
and flirtatious comments it seems his
mind is always on ladybug and never on
catching the villains when stormy
weather announces that summer vacation
is over
cat noir says already but I look so good
in a swimsuit this comment takes ladybug
by surprise and she shoots him oh look
and that's when cat noir flashes her a
cheeky smile ladybug goes on to say the
cat suit will do thanks cat noir
deserves a medal for turning
life-threatening situations into awkward
flirty ones lady Wi-Fi in lady Wi-Fi all
do I get to kuma tais when Khloe gets
her suspended from school convinced that
Chloe is the real lady bug lady Wi-Fi
goes after her and attempts to reveal
her true identity to the world the real
ladybug is Chloe bourgeois everyone but
her plans change when cat noir and the
real ladybug come to Chloe's rescue lady
Wi-Fi is in shock she looks between
Chloe and the real ladybug in disbelief
causing her to ask who are you instead
of letting ladybug answer the question
cat noir buffs up and starts flexing his
muscles it's totally random and
embarrassing is it just us or is he
trying to flirt with lady Wi-Fi the
bubbler in the bubbler Nino gets Akuma
ties by hawkmoth when Adrienne's dad
refuses to allow him to throw Adrien a
birthday party
Nino becomes the bubbler and wishes to
rid the world of controlling parents No
adults means total freedom he ends up
trapping ladybug and cat noir inside of
a huge bubble and he kicks them sky-high
when they attempt to save and defend the
parents of France ladybug tells cat noir
to use his Cataclysm stating that we
can't stay stuck in this bubble together
forever hearing this cat noir Wiggles
his eyebrows and turns on his charm
causing ladybug to groan in frustration
no matter what situation cat noir is in
he always finds a way to hit on ladybug
now that's dedication at its finest time
breaker in time breaker ladybug ends up
travelling backward in time to help her
past self and cat noir defend time
breaker caddy war is totally shocked
when he sees a second ladybug pop out of
nowhere he looks from one ladybug to the
other with a huge smile on his face and
if things weren't awkward enough he goes
on to say to lady books both ladybugs
let out a breath of exasperation when
they hear him say this after all it's
not the first time he's been
inappropriate in the heat of the moment
but we love him just the same
reflector in reflector DeLuca gets Okuma
ties by hawk moth when sabrina traps her
in the washroom on picture day to get
her revenge reflect it turns everyone
into a carbon copy of herself love an
extreme makeover including cat noir when
ladybug realizes that cat noir has been
changed into a reflective look-alike
she's in shock the cat noir takes things
to the next level by saying some of the
cheesiest and dorkiest comments ever
when ladybug asks him if it's really him
he answers course ''tis can't you tell
by my swagger am I still the cat's meow
or what we don't know about you but this
scene made us cringe for days Anna man
we weren't kidding Mooney said that the
last cat you are a moment on this list
is the real deal in the episode Anna man
cat Noir and ladybug are hiding from
Anna man in the dew pain chain bakery
while ladybug is trying to figure out a
way to trap Anna man would that make a
big enough cage cat Noir starts smelling
her she catches him in the act which is
totally awkward
smelling someone is super creepy which
is why we think this miraculous ladybug
moment is the winner do you guys think
the cat noir took things a little too
far when he smelled a ladybug when she
wasn't looking
let us know in the comments section
below and while you're at it tell us who
your favorite miraculous ladybug
character is and why give this video a
big thumbs up if you love cat noir Skadi
puns and be sure to subscribe to the
things for the latest miraculous ladybug
news thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]